(man) THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE HOPEFUL ENTREPRENEURS
COME SEEKING AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS‐‐
FIVE POWERFUL SELF‐MADE
INVESTORS WORTH BILLIONS.
IN THE TANK, THE SHARKS
ARE READY TO INVEST
USING THEIR OWN MONEY...
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU $500,000
FOR 51%.
WELL, MY TIME ALONE
TO WORK ON THIS PROJECT
IS WORTH THE WHOLE COMPANY.
AND YOU'RE TAKING ALL
THE PATENTS INTO CONSIDERATION?
EVERYTHING.
EVERYTHING COMES HOME TO DADDY.
BUT ONLY FOR THE RIGHT PERSON
WITH THE RIGHT BUSINESS.
I LIKE TO HAVE PEOPLE LIKE YOU
DOING ALL THE WORK
SO I CAN SIT AT HOME,
EAT BONBONS.
I HAVE A HARD TIME
LISTENING TO YOU
ONCE YOU'RE STANDING
IN VOMIT.
(all laugh)
IF YOU BLINDFOLDED ME RIGHT NOW,
THAT'S THE SAME PITCH
I GOT ALL MORNING FROM TEN GUYS.
I JUST WANT
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
AND IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GOOD IDEA,
THEY'LL FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A PIECE OF IT.
THIS IS MY MONEY,
AND THIS IS OFFENSIVE.
YOU'RE IN.
BUT FIRST...
OH!
THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST CONVINCE A SHARK
TO INVEST THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
THE CLIPPINGS GENTLY COME DOWN
BEHIND THE MOWER
AND ACTUALLY NATURALLY
FERTILIZE YOUR LAWN.
YOU'RE
A BRILLIANT BUSINESSMAN.
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY ALSO HUMBLE.
THANK YOU.
(sharks laugh)
(laughs)
I DIDN'T THINK WE WERE
COMING IN HERE TO JOKE.
YOUR PRESENTATION WAS A JOKE.
(laughs)
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
KEVIN O'LEARY
KNOWS HOW TO MAKE MONEY.
HE STARTED A SOFTWARE BUSINESS
IN HIS BASEMENT,
WHICH HE EVENTUALLY SOLD
FOR $3.2 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN‐‐
THIS FIERY REAL ESTATE MOGUL
TURNED A $1,000 LOAN
INTO A REAL ESTATE EMPIRE
WORTH HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
IN THE SHARK‐FILLED CITY
OF MANHATTAN.
DAYMOND JOHN TURNED
RAGS TO RICHES
WITH HIS CLOTHING BRAND FUBU,
WHICH HAS GROSSED
OVER $6 BILLION
IN WORLDWIDE RETAIL SALES.
ROBERT HERJAVEC,
THE SON OF A FACTORY WORKER
TURNED TECHNOLOGY MOGUL,
SOLD HIS FIRST
INTERNET COMPANIES
FOR OVER $350 MILLION.
AND TONIGHT, JEFF FOXWORTHY
JOINS THE SHARKS.
THE BEST‐SELLING COMEDY
RECORDING ARTIST OF ALL TIME,
JEFF USED HIS BUSINESS SAVVY
TO BRAND HIS STAND‐UP ROUTINE
INTO A MULTI‐MILLION DOLLAR
MERCHANDISING EMPIRE.
♪♪♪
FIRST INTO THE SHARK TANK IS
LES COOKSON.
HE'S HOPING TO WHET THE SHARKS'
APPETITE WITH HIS IDEA.
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS LES COOKSON.
MY PRODUCT IS THE CARSIK BIB.
I AM SEEKING
A $30,000 INVESTMENT
IN EXCHANGE FOR 15%
OF MY COMPANY.
NOW JUST IMAGINE FOR A MINUTE,
THAT YOU'RE DRIVING
DOWN THE STREET WITH
YOUR BEAUTIFUL LITTLE CHILD HERE
STRAPPED INTO THE CAR SEAT.
(bell dings)
THEN, OUT OF NOWHERE...
OH, GOD!
(Jeff laughs)
(Barbara) OH, NO!
YOU HAD TO PUT
THE CORN IN IT,
DIDN'T YOU, LES? WOW.
(laughs)
LES, I GOTTA KNOW‐‐
WHAT WAS IN THAT STUFF?
WHAT WAS THAT GREEN STUFF?
SPLIT PEA SOUP AND CORN.
FOR THE PARENTS OF THE 58%
OF CHILDREN WHO GET CARSICK,
THIS IS
AN ALL‐TOO‐FAMILIAR SITUATION.
IT IS LIKE DRIVING AROUND
WITH A TICKING TIME BOMB.
YOUR POOR CHILD IS
SOPPING IN VOMIT.
OFTEN, YOU JUST WANT TO THROW
THEIR WHOLE OUTFITS AWAY,
BECAUSE TOUCHING IT IS TOO GROSS
TO EVEN THINK ABOUT.
THIS IS WHY I CREATED
THE CARSIK BIB.
THE CARSIK BIB IS THE SMART,
HANDS‐FREE BARF BAG FOR KIDS.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
(Velcro rips)
YOU ATTACH IT
LIKE A REGULAR BIB.
(sharks laugh)
IT‐‐IT'S A BIB.
IT'S A BIB.
IT'S A CARSIK BIB.
IT'S A FEED BAG, TOO.
(Daymond) YOU KNOW WHAT?
IT'S THE REVERSE FEED BAG.
NO KIDDING.
THEN, YOU KNOW,
WHEN IT HAPPENS...
(man) UGH.
(sharks laugh)
I LOVE IT.
AND‐‐AND IF THE KID
GETS HUNGRY LATER...
YOU STICK A STRAW IN IT.
(laughs)
SERIOUSLY, REGARDLESS
OF WHAT THE KID DOES,
EVERYTHING IS DIRECTED INTO
AND CONTAINED IN THE POUCH.
A PAD IN THE POUCH
SOAKS UP LIQUID,
WHICH PREVENTS SPILLING
AND REDUCES ODOR.
THEN, YOU KNOW,
AFTER IT'S DONE,
YOU FIND A SAFE PLACE
TO PULL OVER.
YOU REMOVE THE CARSIK BIB...
(Velcro rips)
THROW EVERYTHING
IN THE POUCH...
AND THE BOTTOM FLIPS UP,
ZIPS SHUT,
AND YOU THROW IT ALL AWAY.
I WILL SAY THIS‐‐
I HAVE A HARD TIME
LISTENING TO YOU
ONE YOU'RE STANDING IN VOMIT.
(sharks laugh)
HOW DID YOU THINK OF THIS?
I GOTTA KNOW.
WHAT WAS THE MOTIVATION?
WELL, HERE'S THE DEAL.
THIS IS FROM EXPERIENCE.
I HAVE TWO LITTLE BOYS WHO GET
CARSICK, AND THEY THROW UP
AND THEY GIVE NO WARNING.
THERE ARE NO PRODUCTS
THAT DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE.
BUT, LES, I'M DRIVING MY CAR,
AND MY KID'S PUKING IN THE BACK.
HOW DO I TURN AROUND QUICKLY,
PUT IT AROUND HIS NECK OR DO I
JUST PERMANENTLY PUT THAT
ON THE CHILD EVERY DAY
OF HIS LIFE?
EVERY DAY.
WAITING. WAITING.
EVERYWHERE HE GOES.
SOME CHILDREN SERIOUSLY THROW UP
EVERY TIME THEY DRIVE ANYWHERE,
LIKE, 15 MINUTES,
THEY'RE THROWING UP.
CAN I SEE ONE OF THOSE,
PLEASE?
YEAH, YEAH.
(Daymond) JUST GIVE ME ONE.
I MAY NEED IT.
WHAT'S THE COST TO MAKE ONE?
19 CENTS.
INCLUDING THE PAD
AT THE BOTTOM?
YES, INCLUDING. UM...
(laughs) NOW I KNOW
WHY THE KID IS THROWING UP.
IS THIS
A MULTIPURPOSE PRODUCT?
WELL, HERE'S THE DEAL, IS THAT
I HAVE DONE EVERYTHING MYSELF.
I‐I BUILT THE PROTOTYPE MYSELF,
I'VE BEEN SELLING THEM MYSELF,
AND I HAVE BEEN CONSTRUCTING
THEM OF PARTS, YOU KNOW,
LIKE THE‐‐LIKE THE BIB THERE IS
A SHOWER CURTAIN I CUT UP.
SO I'VE, YOU KNOW, I'VE BEEN
USING MY IN‐‐IN, YOU KNOW,
MY, UH...
INGENUITY.
INGENUITY. YOU KNOW, WHEN
IT'S ACTUALLY MANUFACTURED,
UH, PROFESSIONALLY,
IT WILL BE MADE
OF JUST
THE SAME BASIC MATERIALS.
THE ONLY THING I THINK
IS THE‐‐THE‐‐
WORSE THAN VOMITING
IS RIDING AROUND WITH
A BAG OF VOMIT ON YOUR NECK.
(laughs)
HEY, LISTEN, WHEN MY KIDS
WERE LITTLE, THEY WOULD...
(imitates vomiting)
WHACK!
(laughs)
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES?
OKAY, SO I HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE
TO MASS‐PRODUCE THIS.
I JUST HAVE THESE ONES
YOU HAVE HERE.
I, UM, SOLD 'EM ONLINE
WITH A VERY, YOU KNOW,
TEN HITS A DAY ON A WEB SITE‐‐
VERY SMALL TEST RUN.
I SOLD 160 OF 'EM
IN JUST A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
HOW MUCH MONEY
DO YOU HAVE INTO THIS?
UM, $1,300 AND I'VE DONE
EVERYTHING MYSELF.
IF I HAD HIRED OUT EVERYTHING,
I COULD HAVE EASILY SPENT
$10,000, $20,000.
YOU HAVE $1,300,
AND YOU'RE ASKING FOR $30,000
FOR 15%.
RIGHT.
UH, I COULDN'T GIVE YOU
$30,000 FOR THIS.
I'M OUT.
I GOTTA TELL YA, I MEAN, I‐‐
IF I ACTUALLY GAVE YOU 30 GRAND,
I WOULD THROW UP IN THIS THING.
I JUST CAN'T IMAGINE DOING THAT.
IT'S NOT A PLACE
WHERE I WANT TO SAY,
"I MADE A GREAT INVESTMENT TODAY
IN BARF BAGS."
IT DOESN'T LOOK GOOD
IN MY PORTFOLIO.
I'M OUT.
HERE'S ANOTHER THING
I WORRY ABOUT, LES,
IS A LIABILITY ISSUE,
IN THAT YOU GOT A CHILD
YOU CAN'T GET TO
WITH SOMETHING ATTACHED
AROUND ITS NECK.
AND I JUST KNOW KIDS,
AND WHEN SOMETHING HAS
A CHANCE TO GO WRONG,
IT'S GONNA GO WRONG.
TO ANSWER THAT QUESTION‐‐
THERE ARE ALREADY BIBS MADE
FOR‐‐DISPOSABLE BIBS MADE‐‐
APPROVED ON CHILDREN
AS‐‐AS YOUNG AS 6 MONTHS,
AND SO THIS IS NOT SOMETHING
THAT'S UNTESTED OR UNDONE.
I‐I UNDERSTAND THAT,
BUT USUALLY A CHILD WITH
A BIB ON, YOU'RE FEEDING THEM
AND YOU'RE THERE WITH 'EM.
I‐I LIKE YOU A LOT, LES,
AND I‐‐AND I WISH YOU
ALL THE BEST, BUT I'M OUT.
LOOK, LES, I'M LIKE JEFF.
I WORRY ABOUT MY KID BEHIND ME
WITH A PLASTIC BAG
AROUND THEIR NECK
THAT I CAN'T GET TO THEM.
I'M OUT.
I HAVE A 5 YEAR OLD.
I CAN'T IMAGINE HANGING THIS
ON HER NECK.
I'M OUT.
ALL RIGHT, THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL.
(Jeff) YOU BET. GOOD LUCK.
ALL RIGHT. TRY NOT TO TRACK OUT
THE VOMIT TOO FAR, HUH?
NOW WE'VE SEEN EVERYTHING.
I THINK IT STILL HAS
A LOT OF POTENTIAL.
I THINK IT'S SOMETHING
THAT THERE'S A‐‐
THERE'S A HUGE MARKET FOR,
AND THEY DIDN'T SEE IT.
THAT'S FINE. THAT'S FIVE PEOPLE.
THE ARMS ALSO SHOOT NERF BALLS,
SO EVERYBODY DUCK.
(Barbara laughs)
(robotic voice,
speaks indistinctly)
(sharks laugh)
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS CHRIS SPENCER.
I'M FROM HOUSTON, TEXAS.
MY COMPANY IS HYDROMAX.
(man speaks indistinctly)
(man) RACK 'EM UP. HIT HIM
AND DRIVE. RACK 'EM UP. HIT IT.
(whistle blows)
(Chris) IN AMERICA,
THE GAME OF FOOTBALL
IS THE NUMBER ONE SPORT,
AND EVERY YEAR,
THERE'S 14 MILLION KIDS
THAT ARE SUBJECT
TO HAVING HEATSTROKES
AND DEHYDRATION
FROM HEAT‐RELATED INCIDENTS.
KIDS ARE DYING RIGHT NOW,
AND I THINK IT'S UP TO US
TO CREATE A SOLUTION
FOR THE GAME THAT WE LOVE.
SO I'VE BEEN AN ATHLETE
MY WHOLE LIFE.
I WAS ON TRACK
TO GO PROFESSIONAL,
BUT I'VE HAD MORE PASSION
ABOUT THIS
THAN ANY SPORT I'VE EVER PLAYED.
THIS PRODUCT IS LEGIT.
I HAD N. A. S. A. ENGINEERS
REVIEW IT.
HYDROMAX IS GONNA TAKE THE GAME
TO A NEW LEVEL.
BUT IT'S‐‐IT'S ON THE SHELF
RIGHT NOW
'CAUSE I'M FOCUSED
ON SUPPORTING MY FAMILY.
HYDROMAX IS NOT
MY FULL‐TIME JOB.
I'M IN CORPORATE AMERICA
FULL‐TIME,
AND THAT'S WHERE
IT'S BEEN REALLY HARD
TO MAKE THAT DECISION TO GO
INTO BEING AN ENTREPRENEUR.
DO I TAKE THAT RISK? DO I PUT
MY FAMILY IN THAT SITUATION?
OR DO I STAY
IN CORPORATE AMERICA
AND LET A GREAT PRODUCT
GO TO WASTE?
AND THAT'S‐‐THAT'S REALLY
WHERE I NEED HELP.
WITHOUT IT,
HYDROMAX WILL SIT ON THE SHELF,
AND MILLIONS OF KIDS WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AT RISK.
IF I GET AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS,
WE CAN ABSOLUTELY SAVE LIVES.
♪♪♪
YOU READY, MAN?
LET'S DO THIS.
MY NAME IS CHRIS SPENCER
MY COMPANY IS HYDROMAX.
TODAY I'M ASKING FOR $50,000
FOR 25% OF MY COMPANY.
THERE ARE 14 MILLION KIDS
PLAYING THE GAME OF FOOTBALL
TODAY.
TODAY THERE ARE KIDS,
LIKE ETHAN HERE,
THAT ARE DYING OF HAVING
LACK OF HYDRATION
AND THE ABILITY TO GET WATER
WHEN THEY NEED TO
ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
HYDROMAX WILL ALLOW A CHILD
TO HAVE HYDRATION ACCESS
100% OF THE TIME,
WHEN THEY NEED IT, IN BETWEEN
PLAYS ON THE FOOTBALL FIELD.
LET ME BREAK THIS PRODUCT DOWN
FOR YOU.
THERE'S A HYDRATION SYSTEM
THAT MOUNTS
TO THE BACK OF ANY PAIR
OF SHOULDER PADS.
IT ATTACHES WITH VELCRO.
IT HAS A PROTECTIVE SHELL,
SO IT'S IMPACT‐RESISTANT.
IT HOLDS A 16‐OUNCE BLADDER
THAT'S MADE OUT
OF ANTIMICROBIAL MATERIAL.
AND THEN THERE'S A TUBE THAT
COMES AROUND THE SHOULDER PADS
AND HAS A BITE VALVE.
THAT WAY, A CHILD CAN
PULL IT OUT IN BETWEEN PLAYS
WHEN THEY'RE IN A GAME
AND HAVE ACCESS TO WATER.
ETHAN, SHOW THEM HOW EASY IT IS
TO ACCESS WATER.
(gulping)
THAT SIMPLE.
YOU'RE BASICALLY TAKING
A CAMELBAK‐‐
WE USE THOSE FOR RUNNING,
WHEN YOU CAN'T, UH,
GET ACCESS TO WATER.
IS THERE ANY CONCERN WITH
THE WATER SPOUT AT THE END
GETTING CAUGHT IN HIS NECK?
IT'S ACTUALLY HELD FIRMLY
AGAINST THE CHEST WITH VELCRO.
AND THE REASON IT'S POINTING
DOWNWARD IN THE TIGHT JERSEY
IS SO THAT WAY,
IT DOESN'T JUST FLAP UP.
HOW MUCH MORE DOES THAT PAD COST
TO A TRADITIONAL PAD?
THIS PAD IS ACTUALLY A SEPARATE
BRAND OF SHOULDER PADS.
THIS SYSTEM MOUNTS
TO ANY PAIR OF SHOULDER PADS.
NOW THE VISION
WOULD BE MAYBE ONE DAY,
YOU KNOW, WE GET THE PRODUCT TO
THE MARKET, MAYBE WE CAN PARTNER
WITH A COMPANY AND BUILD IT
INTO THE SHOULDER PADS,
TO WHERE THIS CAN BE ATTACHED
TO EVERY SINGLE PAIR
OF SHOULDER PADS,
LIKE A SEAT BELT IS IN A CAR.
AND I ASSUME THAT THIS IS
A PATENTED PRODUCT?
YES.
CHRIS, CAN I BUY THIS
FOR FOOTBALL
AND USE IT FOR SOMETHING ELSE?
IT'S DESIGNED FOR FOOTBALL.
I THINK WHAT HE'S ASKING‐‐
WELL, CAN YOU MAKE IT FIT
THE BACK OF A SUIT JACKET,
WITH SCOTCH IN IT,
WHERE IT WOULD JUST
COME AROUND...
(sharks laugh)
JEFF, YOU READ MY MIND. THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT I WAS ASKING.
(chuckles) SO IF WE BRING YOU
THIS PRODUCT RIGHT HERE,
AND IT COMES PREPACKAGED
WITH A BOTTLE.
AND YOU FILL IT UP. OKAY.
MM‐HMM.
CHRIS, WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR
AND WHAT DO YOU PAY FOR IT
TO BE MANUFACTURED?
$49.99.
$8.50 TO MANUFACTURE IT.
AND DO YOU HAVE SALES TODAY,
CHRIS?
I HAD SALES IN 2007.
IN 2007, I WAS SINGLE.
AND I FELL IN LOVE
WITH MY BEAUTIFUL WIFE,
AND I DECIDED TO CHANGE
MY CAREER PATH.
I WENT TO CORPORATE AMERICA,
AND I WASN'T ABLE
TO RUN MY COMPANY FULL‐TIME.
CHRIS, DOES YOUR‐‐
DOES YOUR WIFE WORK?
YES, SHE'S A TEACHER,
FULL‐TIME.
CHRIS, I DON'T THINK
YOU MENTIONED
WHAT YOUR SALES WERE
BACK IN 2007.
$100,000 WORTH OF SALES
IN 2007.
WHY COULD YOU AFFORD
TO BE AN ENTREPRENEUR NOW?
WHAT'S CHANGED?
I WORK FOR A GREAT COMPANY.
NO, BUT HOW WOULD
YOU MAKE THE TIME, THOUGH,
IS WHAT I'M QUESTIONING.
WELL, I'M HOPING I CAN GET
A DISTRIBUTION DEAL
OR SOMETHING IN PLACE,
TO WHERE I CAN SHIFT MY FOCUS
AND DO THIS FULL‐TIME.
IT'S A REALLY CLEVER DESIGN.
DID YOU COME UP WITH THIS?
YES. I DESIGNED IT.
I‐I WAS AN ATHLETE.
I‐I ENVISIONED IT WHEN I WAS
ACTUALLY IN HIGH SCHOOL,
'CAUSE I HAD THIS ISSUE.
NOW E‐EVERY SUMMER, I'M READING
ABOUT SOME KID IN HIGH SCHOOL
DYING FROM BEING OVERHEATED
OR‐‐OR WHATEVER. I MEAN‐‐
COLLEGE, HIGH SCHOOL.
YEAH.
WHAT YOU NEED IS TO GET
A LARGE MANUFACTURER/DISTRIBUTOR
TO TAKE THIS ON
AND PAY YOU A LICENSE.
YOU DON'T ACTUALLY HAVE THE TIME
TO GO DO THAT BECAUSE YOU'RE
WORKING FULL‐TIME SUPPORTING
YOUR FAMILY. THAT'S YOUR STORY.
YOU WANT SOMEONE HERE
TO DO THAT.
I LIKE TO HAVE PEOPLE
LIKE YOU DOING ALL THE WORK
SO I CAN SIT AT HOME,
EAT BONBONS.
THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO DO.
NOBODY WANTS TO SAVE CHILDREN
MORE THAN I DO, PARTICULARLY
IF I CAN PROFIT FROM IT.
I LOVE THAT PART.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IT'S A CHALLENGE THAT
I DON'T WANT TO TAKE ON.
I'M OUT.
CHRIS, THE VALUATION
OF YOUR BUSINESS IS WAY OFF,
BASICALLY VALUING THE COMPANY
AT $200,000. I'M OUT.
CHRIS, I DON'T HAVE
THE CONTACTS YOU NEED,
AND I DON'T HAVE THE TIME
THAT IT'S GONNA TAKE
TO MAKE THIS BUSINESS GO.
SO I'M OUT.
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
JEFF AND ROBERT
ARE CHRIS' LAST CHANCES
TO KEEP HIS DREAM ALIVE.
♪♪♪
THREE SHARKS ARE OUT.
JEFF AND ROBERT ARE CHRIS'
LAST CHANCES TO MAKE A DEAL.
CHRIS, IT'S CLEVER.
VERY CLEVER.
BUT...
SOMETIMES IN LIFE, YOU JUST
CAN'T AVOID HARD WORK.
YOU GOTTA GO OUT THERE
AND‐‐AND SELL THIS.
ROBERT,
IF‐‐IF‐‐IF WE DID A DEAL,
I'M GONNA BE COMPLETELY HUMBLE
IN THE PROCESS.
I JUST WANT TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
IT'S A GREAT PRODUCT.
IT'S NOT ABOUT ME RIGHT NOW.
IT'S ABOUT HIM.
HE'S STILL GONNA BE OUT THERE
RIGHT NOW,
IN 100‐DEGREE TEMPERATURE,
PLAYING FOOTBALL IN TEXAS,
AND COULD DIE.
YOU NEED TO MAKE
SOME SALES CALLS, MY FRIEND,
'CAUSE I THINK THE ONLY GUY
WHO CAN REALLY DO THIS IS YOU.
YOU JUST GOTTA FIND A WAY.
SO I'M OUT.
HAS THIS BEEN USED
IN HIGH SCHOOL OR COLLEGE GAMES
AND‐‐AND PROVEN TO WORK?
YES, SIR. ABSOLUTELY.
I'VE HAD PLAYERS IN COLLEGE
WEAR IT.
IT WAS IN THE 2007 HULA BOWL.
WHAT ARE YOUR EXPANSION PLANS?
WHAT‐‐WHAT ARE YOU LOOKING AT
DOWN THE ROAD?
MY EXPANSION PLAN WOULD BE
TO GET IT ON KIDS' SHOULDER PADS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY FIRST,
THEN HOPEFULLY, WE CAN BUILD IT
IN THE SHOULDER PADS.
MY PATENT WOULD PROTECT THAT.
WE CAN GET
INTO CAMELBAK'S MARKET.
CAMELBAK SIGNED A $100 MILLION
DEAL WITH THE MILITARY
WHEN THEY LAUNCHED
THEIR PRODUCT.
WE CAN GET INTO THAT MARKET.
THEIR PATENT DOES NOT PROTECT
A HYDRATION SYSTEM.
HERE'S WHERE WE STAND.
OKAY.
YOU DON'T HAVE THE TIME
TO DO THIS.
YOU'VE GOT ANOTHER JOB.
YOU'VE GOT A NEW FAMILY.
CORRECT.
YOU NEED SOMEBODY TO STEP IN.
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT IDEA,
AND THAT'S WHERE IT STARTS.
YES, SIR.
BUT YOU GOTTA RUN
THIS BUSINESS.
I'LL GO $50,000...
FOR 50%.
I'LL PARTNER WITH YOU.
JEFF, YOU'RE GETTING OUT
OF THE COMEDY BUSINESS?
YOU'RE GONNA START SELLING
HYDRATION BAGS?
I'M IN THE IDEA BUSINESS.
HE'S GOT A GREAT IDEA.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE YOUR MONEY
ON EVERYBODY'S MOTHER THAT HAS
A KID THAT PLAYS LITTLE LEAGUE,
GOING "I WANT"‐‐
YEAH, ABSOLUTELY.
EVERY WORRIED MOTHER OUT THERE.
TO ME, IT'S A GREAT IDEA,
AND‐‐AND‐‐AND STRICTLY
FROM THE STANDPOINT
OF CONCERNED MOMS AND DADS.
AND‐‐AND HERE'S THE DEAL‐‐ONCE
ONE KID ON THE TEAM HAS IT...
EVERYBODY HAS TO HAVE IT.
EVERYBODY'S GOTTA HAVE IT.
I'M ALL ABOUT KIDS.
WORK WITH
CHILDREN'S HOSPITALS,
HOST A KIDS' SHOW,
WRITE CHILDREN'S BOOKS.
I‐I THINK THAT'S YOUR MARKET
FOR THAT.
YOU AND I PARTNER TOGETHER
ON THIS, WE'LL MAKE THIS WORK.
YOU'VE GOT AN OFFER
ON THE TABLE.
I SAY YOU HAVE A DEAL.
(Jeff) WHOO! WHOO!
(laughs) THAT'S AWESOME.
YOU'RE GONNA BE GLAD
YOU DID THIS.
YOU KNOW, I'M SMARTER
THAN A FIFTH GRADER.
I'M NOT. I'M GLAD YOU ARE,
'CAUSE I'M NOT.
WE DID IT, ETHAN.
VERY EXCITING.
(Barbara laughs)
THERE YOU GO, BABY.
WHOO!
(Daymond) CONGRATULATIONS.
AND YOU KNOW, IT'S‐‐
IT ALL STARTS WITH THE IDEA.
IT'S A GREAT IDEA.
STOP GLOATING, FOR GOD SAKES.
(laughs)
WHOO! I GOT A DEAL, BABY.
IT'S GOOD.
♪♪♪
LAST SEASON, WE WATCHED
CACTUS JACK STRIKE A DEAL
WITH KEVIN HARRINGTON
FOR HIS FITNESS EQUIPMENT,
THE BODY JAC.
I'LL TAKE YOUR DEAL.
(Barbara) WHOO!
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY. GOOD JOB.
(man) LET'S SEE
WHAT HE'S UP TO NOW.
WE'RE HERE IN LAS VEGAS,
AT THE BIGGEST INFOMERCIAL
CONVENTION IN THE WORLD.
I BELIEVE SO MUCH
IN CACTUS JACK'S BODY JAC,
THAT I BROUGHT HIM
TO THIS SHOW,
WITH SOME OF THE BIGGEST NAMES
IN THE BUSINESS.
(Jack) THE BODY JAC IS
A PUSH‐UP MACHINE
THAT HELPS TO MAKE THE PUSH‐UP
EASIER AND FUN.
SEE HOW IT HELPS
BRING YOU BACK UP?
WOW.
OH, YEAH.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HOW THE WHOLE
THING HAS COME TOGETHER, AND I‐‐
VERY HONESTLY, I COULDN'T HAVE
DONE IT WITHOUT "SHARK TANK."
WHEN KEVIN ANNOUNCED
HE WAS GONNA ACTUALLY SHOOT
AN INFOMERCIAL ON THE PRODUCT,
IT'S JUST LIKE
A DREAM COME TRUE.
WE'RE HERE TO DEBUT
THE BODY JAC BY CACTUS JACK.
(cheering)
WATCH THIS.
YOU'RE GONNA ENJOY THIS.
(woman) INTRODUCING
THE INCREDIBLE
NEW BODY JAC FITNESS SYSTEM.
(Harrington) WHEN BARBARA AND I
MADE OUR DEAL WITH CACTUS JACK,
I KNEW THAT THE INFOMERCIAL
WAS THE BEST WAY
TO SELL THIS PRODUCT
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
MY COMPANY HAS THE CHANCE TO DO
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN BUSINESS
WITH CACTUS JACK BODY JAC.
I'M SURE YOU RECOGNIZE
THIS GUY.
THIS IS KEVIN HARRINGTON
WITH "SHARK TANK"
AND ONE OF THE PEOPLE
HE DISCOVERED‐‐CACTUS JACK.
HOW ARE YOU GUYS?
(Jack) A LOT OF PEOPLE
DON'T REALLY BELIEVE
THAT SOME OF THESE SHARK DEALS
ARE FOR REAL.
I'M LIVING PROOF THAT
THESE THINGS DO HAPPEN
AND DREAMS CAN COME TRUE.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE GOTTA DO NOW.
WE GOTTA SELL, SELL, SELL.
HOW ABOUT A "YEE‐HA"?
AH, YEE‐HA!
♪♪♪
(man) NEXT INTO THE SHARK TANK
IS ANDY HUMPHREY,
WITH A COMPANY LOOKING
TO CAPITALIZE
ON THE TREND
IN ECO‐FRIENDLY PRODUCTS.
I'M ANDY HUMPHREY,
AND MY COMPANY IS ECOMOWERS.
I'M SEEKING $90,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 20% OF MY COMPANY.
I BROUGHT WITH ME
A LAWN MOWER.
NOW THIS LAWN MOWER
IS JUST LIKE
THE LAWN MOWER THAT MOST
AMERICANS HAVE IN THEIR GARAGE.
IT'S HEAVY, IT'S DIRTY,
IT'S LOUD,
AND IT'S DANGEROUS.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT,
THE BLADES ON THIS LAWN MOWER
SPIN AT OVER
150 MILES PER HOUR,
AND THEY CAUSE NEARLY 80,000
HOSPITAL INJURIES EVERY YEAR.
BUT THAT'S NOT
THE REASON I'M HERE.
THE REASON I'M HERE IS BECAUSE
LAWN MOWERS ARE TERRIBLE,
TERRIBLE FOR THE ENVIRONMENT.
EMISSIONS FROM LAWN MOWERS IS
TOTALLY UNREGULATED,
AND THE AMOUNT OF POLLUTION
THAT'S EMITTED
IN JUST ONE HOUR
OF USING A LAWN MOWER
IS LIKE DRIVING TEN CARS.
REALLY?
WHY IS EVERYBODY TALKING ABOUT
CARS WHEN LAWN MOWERS ARE
WORSE FOR THE ENVIRONMENT?
THEY ARE BIG‐TIME POLLUTERS.
SO THE NEXT BIG
BILLION‐DOLLAR MOVEMENT
IS REDUCING EMISSIONS
FROM LAWN AND GARDEN EQUIPMENT.
WHO SAID?
THE E. P. A. IS ABOUT
TO REGULATE, COME 2012,
EMISSIONS
ON LAWN AND GARDEN EQUIPMENT,
AND IT'S ALREADY STARTING NOW.
SO I'VE COME UP
WITH A FANTASTIC SOLUTION,
AND IT'S CALLED THE ECOMOWER.
THE ECOMOWER IS THE WORLD'S
MOST ECO‐FRIENDLY LAWN MOWER‐‐
REQUIRES NO GAS, NO BATTERIES,
AND IT'S COMPLETELY SILENT.
SO LET ME GIVE YOU A QUICK
EXAMPLE ON HOW IT WORKS.
SO THE ECOMOWER
PUSHES WITH EASE.
IT'S VERY, VERY, VERY EASY
TO PUSH IT.
AND YOU'LL NOTICE
THAT AS I CUT THE GRASS,
THE CLIPPINGS GENTLY COME DOWN
BEHIND THE MOWER
AND ACTUALLY NATURALLY
FERTILIZE YOUR LAWN.
NOW THE REASON THAT
THIS ISN'T YOUR GRANDFATHER'S
OLD LAWN MOWER
IS THAT IT HAS
A FRICTIONLESS CUTTING SYSTEM.
WHEN THESE BLADES SPIN,
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NOT TOUCHING.
THERE'S A VERY SMALL GAP
THAT CREATES NO FRICTION,
NO CONTACT,
AND THE BEAUTY OF THAT IS
YOU DON'T HAVE TO SHARPEN IT.
I‐I‐I‐I AM TOTALLY LOST.
(Robert) LOST WHAT?
GUYS, WHAT ARE YOU TALK‐‐
"THE GRASS FALL GENTLY
BEHIND THE MOWER"?
THIS IS LIKE WHAT WE CALL
ROMANCING THE TRUTH.
SO DO YOU GUYS NOT BELIEVE THAT
ECO‐FRIENDLY LAWN MOWERS IS
GOING TO BE THE CATEGORY
OF THE FUTURE?
I‐I‐‐THERE'S A WHOLE CATEGORY
OF PUSHED MOWERS.
(Robert) WELL, HOW BIG IS
THAT MARKET TODAY?
AND‐‐AND WHO SAYS THAT THOSE
CAN'T RUN
JUST AS EASILY AS THIS ONE?
SORRY, DAYMOND. ARE YOU SAYING
WHY ISN'T HE COMPARING THIS
TO THE ONES
THAT ALREADY EXIST?
THE‐‐THE PUSH MOWERS THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST ON THE MARKET.
DAY‐‐LET ME INTERPRET.
I‐I'M‐‐I'M
TOTALLY LOST HERE.
DAYMOND IS BASICALLY SAYING
ANDY'S BAIT AND SWITCHING.
ISN'T THAT
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING?
YEAH. HEY, GUYS, WE'RE GONNA
REDUCE THE EMISSIONS ON CARS
BECAUSE I'VE INVENTED
A BICYCLE.
(Robert) OKAY.
BUT, ANDY, ANSWER THAT.
YEAH. SO THERE'S ROUGHLY
HALF A MILLION PUSH MOWERS SOLD.
HALF A MILLION?
ALL THOSE MOWERS REQUIRE
SHARPENING AND THEY'RE HARDER
TO PUSH AND THEY'RE‐‐
YOU'RE BASICALLY SAYING
YOU'RE BUILDING A BETTER BIKE.
REALLY, THE THING THAT MAKES
THIS DIFFERENT‐‐AND STOP ME
IF I'M WRONG‐‐IS THAT
YOU DON'T NEED TO SHARPEN IT.
THAT'S CORRECT.
AND WE KNOW FOR A FACT
THAT NO OTHER, UH, LAWN MOWER
HAS THAT ABILITY?
WELL, I DON'T KNOW THAT
FOR A FACT.
WELL, WE HAVE TO TAKE HIM‐‐
ARE YOU THE ONLY ONE
THAT YOU DON'T HAVE
TO SHARPEN THE BLADES?
UH, CURRENTLY IN THE U. S.,
THAT‐‐YES.
THERE'S‐‐THERE'S
SOME GERMAN PRODUCTS
AND SOME PRODUCTS IN EUROPE.
UM...
SO THE REAL VALUE
IN THIS BUSINESS
IS NOT THE FACT THAT
IT DOESN'T NEED SHARPENING.
THIS IS A WAY FOR US
TO CREATE,
UH, A NAME AND AS‐ASSIMILATION
WITH A BRAND.
THIS IS A BRANDING PLATE.
FORGET THE MOWERS.
IT'S A BRANDING PLATE.
RIGHT. SO‐‐SO I STARTED
THIS BUSINESS, UM,
AS AN ONLINE STORE, RIGHT,
'CAUSE I WANTED TO‐‐
I WANTED TO MAKE MONEY
FROM DAY ONE.
AND SO WHAT I DID IS I STARTED
RETAILING ALL THE OLD,
YOU KNOW, THE PUSH MOWERS THAT
ARE OUT THERE ON THE MARKET,
AND THIS YEAR
I'M UP TO $350,000 IN SALES.
OF YOUR COMPETING PRODUCTS.
CORRECT.
SO DID YOU SELL ECOMOWERS
OR OTHER GUYS'?
THIS IS A PROTOTYPE MOWER.
I'M LOOKING TO YOU
TO HELP ME MANUFACTURE THIS.
I'M SELLING
OTHER PEOPLE'S MOWERS.
SO YOU SOLD $350,000
OF THE TRADITIONAL PUSH MOWERS
BUT NONE OF THE ECOMOWER.
NOT THIS MOWER, CORRECT.
OH, COME ON.
AND WHEN YOU THINK
OF THE NAME "ECOMOWER,"
THERE IS NOTHING
MORE ECO‐FRIENDLY WITH THIS‐‐
WHY DON'T YOU JUST GO
TO A LARGE MANUFACTURER
AND SAY, "I WANT
TO PRIVATE LABEL YOUR MOWER
AND PUT MY BRAND ON IT"? BECAUSE
LOTS OF GUYS MANUFACTURE THESE.
MANY OF THEM ARE MADE IN CHINA,
AND YOU CAN SAY,
"MINE IS THE ECOMOWER."
WHY CAN'T YOU DO THAT?
ANDY, WHY‐‐WHY CAN'T
THE BIG GUY IN THAT SPACE
REBRAND HIS PRODUCT
AS THE "GREEN‐CUT MOWER"
OR THE "BABY SEAL MOWER"
OR THE "FRIENDLY MOWER"
AND COMPETE WITH YOU?
BECAUSE THE ECOMOWER‐‐THAT'S
WHAT PEOPLE ASSOCIATE WITH.
I WANT TO SEARCH
FOR AN ECO‐FRIENDLY LAWN MOWER.
ARE THERE
ECO‐FRIENDLY LAWN MOWERS?
ECO‐FRIENDLY LAWN MOWER IS‐‐IS
WHAT PEOPLE ASSOCIATE WITH.
YOU BUILT THAT MOWER
RIGHT THERE?
THIS IS A PROTOTYPE.
I DIDN'T BUILD THIS MYSELF.
I HAD A FACTORY
WORKING ON IT.
SO YOU DID EXACTLY WHAT I SAID.
YOU WENT TO A MANUFACTURER,
BASICALLY PUT YOUR BRAND
ON SOMEBODY'S MANUFACTURING‐‐
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
LET ME‐‐LET ME‐‐
(Kevin) YOU'RE IN.
NO. I'M GONNA DO THIS.
I'M GONNA CREATE A COMPANY
CALLED GREEN MOWERS,
AND I SWEAR TO YOU,
FOR $450,000,
I KNOW A GUY IN THE 'HOOD
WHO WILL SHARPEN
EVERYBODY'S MOWER
FOR THE REST OF HIS LIFE.
(Kevin and Jeff laugh)
MAN, I R‐‐I DIDN'T THINK WE WERE
COMING IN HERE TO JOKE.
BUT, ANDY, YOUR PRESENTATION WAS
A JOKE, WITH ALL DUE RESPECT.
IT GOT YOUR ATTENTION,
THOUGH, RIGHT?
I AM OUT.
CAN I SAY ONE MORE THING?
HALF THE PEOPLE‐‐NOT HALF‐‐
BUT A HIGH PERCENTAGE
OF THE MAJORITY OF THE PEOPLE
THAT BUY THESE MOWERS
DO IT 'CAUSE YOU BURN
OVER 400 CALORIES AN HOUR.
THERE'S THIS WHOLE SECTION
OF THE MARKET
THAT WANTS TO MOW THE LAWN
TO STAY HEALTHY AND STAY FIT
BUT THEY'RE ALREADY DOING IT
WITH EVERYBODY ELSE'S MOWER.
THE VALUE IS
IN THE NAME "ECOMOWER."
IT'S IN THE NAME.
I‐I THINK THE PRESENTATION
SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABOUT
"I'VE LICENSED IT TO THE BIGGEST
MANUFACTURER IN THIS MARKET
AND THAT MARKET," AND WE'RE
GONNA GET SOMETHING FOR IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WOULD WORK,
BUT FOR ME,
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TODAY.
I'M OUT.
YOU'RE OUT.
(man) BARBARA?
I DON'T HAVE THAT MUCH
CONFIDENCE IN THE NAME,
AND I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA HAVE ENORMOUS COMPETITION,
SO I'M OUT.
I THINK YOU'VE PROVEN
THAT YOU'RE A SUCCESSFUL
ONLINE RETAILER OF MOWERS.
NOW YOU WANNA BECOME
A MANUFACTURER AND BRAND THEM.
I'M CONFUSED AND NOT
THAT INTERESTED. I'M OUT.
YOU KNOW, I‐I MEAN,
I CAN SEE, IN THE FUTURE,
MORE PEOPLE DOING THIS,
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE OUT HERE
WITH SMALL LAWNS.
YEAH, YOU'VE GOT THE NAME,
AND I THINK IT'S A COOL NAME.
YOU HAVEN'T SOLD ONE OF THEM.
YOU KNOW THAT IT'S BETTER
THAN THE ONES
THAT I HAVE BEEN SELLING.
WE DON'T KNOW IF IT'S BETTER
THAN THE OTHER ONES,
'CAUSE YOU DIDN'T BRING
ONE OF THE OTHER ONES HERE.
YOU KNOW WHAT? I'M SORRY.
I'M OUT.
SO LET ME ASK YOU THIS‐‐
NOW THAT WE'RE ALL‐‐
YOU ARE ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE‐‐
IF I COULD'VE DONE ONE THING
BETTER, WHAT WOULD THAT BE?
NOT COME HERE.
DON'T ASK ME TO INVEST
IN A PRODUCT
YOU HAVEN'T SOLD ONE OF.
YOU CREATED A BRAND,
YOU PUT THAT BRAND
ON SOMEONE ELSE'S MOWER,
AND YOU HAVEN'T SOLD ONE YET.
THIS IS OFFENSIVE. I MEAN,
HE'S ASKING FOR $90,000.
HE HAS NOT SOLD ONE.
HIS SALES PITCH WAS
"THE GRASS FALLS GENTLY
BEHIND THE MOWER."
ANDY, I WOULD SAY
YOUR PRESENTATION
MET WITH LIMITED SUCCESS.
(Robert laughs)
I DON'T CARE IF YOU GUYS
AREN'T ECO‐PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW, THERE'S A WHOLE
SECTION OF AMERICA‐‐
OH, NOBODY'S MORE ECO
THAN ME.
THAT HAS NOTHING
TO DO WITH IT.
ANDY, ANOTHER PIECE
OF ADVICE‐‐
DON'T INSULT THE PEOPLE
YOU'RE ASKING MONEY FROM.
NEVER A GOOD APPROACH.
I THINK WE'RE ALL ECO,
UH, CONSCIOUS HERE.
(Kevin) ALL RIGHT.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
(mouths words)
WE'RE GONNA ELIMINATE
EMISSIONS
BY SELLING WHAT PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
SELLING FOR YEARS,
EVEN BEFORE EMISSIONS STARTED.
I DIDN'T LIKE THAT "OH, WELL,
YOU'RE NOT ECO‐FRIENDLY"
BECAUSE I DON'T BUY YOUR THING.
THAT WASN'T COOL.
THAT WAS HIM MAKING AN EXCUSE
FOR HIMSELF.
YEAH, I KINDA LIKED HIM UP TILL
THAT POINT. LIKE, REALLY?
THE NEXT TIME
ONE OF THE SHARKS,
UH, WAKES UP IN THE MORNING‐‐
THE EARLY MORNING‐‐
TO THE SOUND
OF HIS NEIGHBOR'S LAWN MOWER,
HE'S REALLY GONNA BE WISHING
HE HAD THEM USING ECOMOWERS.
♪♪♪
MY NAME IS DAVID PIKOFF,
AND THIS IS MY BROTHER STUART.
WE'RE FROM AUSTIN, TEXAS.
TOGETHER, WE'RE
THE COFOUNDERS OF GAMES2U.
SO THERE WAS A POINT
AT WHICH I WAS PUTTING TOGETHER
MY SON'S BIRTHDAY PARTY AT HOME,
AND I REALIZED THERE WAS
NOTHING NEW SINCE WE WERE KIDS.
IT WAS BOUNCE HOUSES,
PETTING ZOOS, MAGICIANS‐‐
ALL THAT SAME OLD BORING STUFF,
SO WE SET OUT
TO CHANGE ALL THAT.
WE HAVE THE MOST UNIQUE
MOBILE ENTERTAINMENT COMPANY
ON THE PLANET. ONE OF THE BIG
REASONS WHY IS THE MAGIC
THAT HAPPENS RIGHT HERE
IN THE FUN FACTORY.
COME ON. I'LL SHOW YOU.
HIT IT, BOYS.
(laughs) HERE WE GO.
(David) WE ARE THE FIRST
AND ONLY MOBILE ENTERTAINMENT
COMPANY OF ITS KIND.
(Stuart) BASICALLY,
WE BRING THE COOLEST STUFF TO
YOUR DOORSTEP.
AAH!
NO! OH, MY GOD!
THIS IS TOTALLY DIFFERENT
FROM ANYTHING WE'VE DONE, TOO.
THAT'S GREAT.
YOU KNOW, WORKING TOGETHER
AS BROTHERS IS A LOT OF FUN.
I'VE KNOWN THE GUY
MY WHOLE LIFE.
AND I DO ALL THE HARD WORK,
HE TAKES ALL THE CREDIT.
YEAH. AND IF THINGS DON'T
WORK OUT, I JUST TELL MOM.
(children screaming)
(children laughing)
THE FIRST EVENT,
THE KIDS CAME UP TO US.
THEY WERE HUGGING OUR LEGS
AND TELLING US IT WAS
THE GREATEST DAY
OF THEIR LIFE,
AND AT THAT POINT, WE KNEW
WE WERE ON TO SOMETHING.
GAMES2U HAS OVER
140 FRANCHISE TERRITORIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY NOW.
FRANCHISEES ARE THRIVING,
DOING FANTASTIC.
THIS IS A PERFECT OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE SHARKS TO COME IN
AND INVEST
IN AN AMAZING, GROWING BRAND.
(children screaming)
(lasers firing)
OH, BOY.
(siren wailing)
(chuckles)
THEY'RE ON TO YOU, KEVIN. RUN.
I'M SOLD.
THAT'S COOL.
HI. I'M STUART PIKOFF.
THIS IS MY BROTHER DAVID.
(robotic voice)
HELLO, SHARKS.
(laughs)
TOGETHER WE'RE
THE COFOUNDERS OF GAMES2U.
WE'RE HERE TODAY SEEKING
A $500,000 INVESTMENT
FOR A 10% EQUITY STAKE
IN GAMES2U.
(David, normal voice) MY BROTHER
AND I ARE KIDS AT HEART.
THREE YEARS AGO,
WE STARTED GAMES2U,
THE FIRST AND ONLY
NATIONALLY BRANDED
MOBILE ENTERTAINMENT COMPANY
OF ITS KIND.
GAMES2U HAS
SPECIALIZED VEHICLES.
INSIDE OF OUR VEHICLES,
WE'VE GOT 4‐D MOVIE THEATERS
AND MOBILE VIDEO GAME THEATERS.
WE HAVE ALL KINDS
OF OTHER CRAZY, FUN STUFF‐‐
THINGS LIKE BOOGER WARS.
YES, BOOGER WARS.
AND Ubot,
WHERE YOU BECOME THE ROBOT.
NOW OUR COMPANY IS SET UP
AS A FRANCHISING ORGANIZATION.
TODAY WE HAVE
OVER 140 FRANCHISE TERRITORIES
SOLD IN 28 STATES,
AND WE DO OVER 2,000 PARTIES
AND EVENTS EACH AND EVERY MONTH.
ANYBODY WANT TO TAKE A SPIN
IN THE Ubot?
YEAH, I'LL TAKE IT.
HOW DOES IT WORK?
HOP ON IN. IT'S GOT
AN ADJUSTABLE PLATFORM,
SO IT ADJUSTS
TO ANY HEIGHT, AND‐‐
ARE YOU CALLING ME SHORT?
(laughs) NO.
(robotic voice)
HOW DO I TALK INTO IT?
(laughs)
AND WHEN YOU TALK, IT'S GOT
VOICE MODULATION, AS YOU SEE.
(normal voice)
OH, IT'S EASY TO USE.
THE ARMS ALSO SHOOT NERF BALLS,
SO EVERYBODY DUCK.
(lasers firing)
(Daymond and Barbara laugh)
(robotic voice) WELL,
I'M MR. WONDERFUL NOW. HA HA.
(sharks laugh)
WELL DONE. WELL DONE.
(normal voice) I LIKE IT. IT'S
FUN. DID YOU GUYS MAKE THIS?
WE DID.
IT'S A PATENTED PRODUCT.
YOU INVENTED THIS,
THIS WHOLE THING?
YES, SIR.
WOW. IT KINDA REMINDS ME
OF DAYMOND‐‐SHORT, STOCKY.
(laughs)
LITTLE BIT.
SO LET ME ASK YOU THIS,
STUART.
I ASK YOU TO COME TO MY HOUSE
FOR MY KID'S BIRTHDAY.
WHAT DOES THAT COST?
TYPICAL EVENT AT A HOME BIRTHDAY
PARTY IS GONNA BE $300 TO $400.
IT'S JUST GONNA BE
ABOUT AN HOUR AND A HALF OF
ENTERTAINMENT BY THE FRANCHISE.
THE MORE LUCRATIVE BUSINESS
THE FRANCHISES HAVE
IS THE CORPORATE‐‐
CORPORATE TEAM‐BUILDING EVENTS,
THE SCHOOL FUND‐RAISERS.
SO WHAT‐‐WHAT DOES THAT COST
A CORPORATION TO HIRE YOU?
THEY'RE GONNA SPEND UP TO A FEW
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR AN EVENT.
YOU PUT
A VALUE OF YOUR BUSINESS
BY ASKING ME
FOR $500,000 FOR 10%.
YOU'RE TELLING ME
IT'S WORTH $5 MILLION.
YES, SIR.
OKAY. HUMOR ME. YOU'D BETTER
HAVE SOME FANTASTIC SALES.
(laughs) AND WE DO.
LAST YEAR WE DID
$3.5 MILLION IN GROSS SALES.
THIS YEAR WE'RE UP 65%.
WE'RE TRACKING FOR $5 MILLION
IN TOP LINE SALES.
MM.
I REALLY WANNA KNOW
WHAT BOOGER WARS IS.
(chuckles)
BOOGER WARS IS A GREAT GAME.
IT'S BASICALLY A CROSS BETWEEN
CAPTURE THE FLAG AND DODGEBALL.
IF YOU GET BOOGERED,
YOU'RE OUT.
HOW DOES IT WORK?
WELL, YOU'VE GOT
THESE VESTS OVER HERE.
BOOGERS GET THROWN. THEY STICK,
YOU'RE BOOGERED, YOU'RE OUT.
(rips Velcro)
IT'S A SIMPLE GAME,
BUT IT IS A TON OF FUN.
IS THIS
ONE OF YOUR CREATIONS?
IT IS.
IT'S A PATENTED PRODUCT.
PATENTED PRODUCT.
SO IF WE INVEST
IN THE COMPANY,
ARE WE OWNERS ON
ALL THE PATENTS AS WELL?
ABSOLUTELY. WE HAVE
SIX PATENTS CURRENTLY...
WE HAVE TEN TRADEMARKS.
AND GAMES2U HAS
SO MANY DIFFERENT PRODUCTS.
YOU'RE LOOKING
AT JUST A FEW HERE TODAY.
WE'VE GOT A LOT
OF OTHER UNIQUE PRODUCTS.
WE'RE ALWAYS GONNA BE
CREATING NEW THINGS.
WHAT'S MORE IMPORTANT‐‐
OUR FRANCHISEES ARE
WILDLY SUCCESSFUL.
WILDLY SUCCESSFUL FRANCHISEES
COUPLED WITH
HUGE CONSUMER DEMAND‐‐THAT'S
WHAT MAKES A WINNING FORMULA
FOR A FRANCHISING ORGANIZATION,
AND THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE.
DAVID,
YOUR REVE‐‐YOUR SALES‐‐
ARE THEY YOUR SALES,
INCLUDING THE FRANCHISEE SALES?
NO, SIR. THOSE ARE PURELY
OUR SALES. CORPORATE.
SO WHAT I'M ASKING YOU IS,
YOU SELL THE LICENSE
TO THE FRANCHISEES,
AND THEY SELL
THEIR OWN STUFF?
CORRECT.
RIGHT. A FRANCHISEE‐‐
WHEN THEY INVEST,
THEY GET A PROTECTED TERRITORY.
THEY GET A SPECIALIZED VEHICLE
LIKE YOU SEE. THEY GET
A VAST ARRAY OF OUR EQUIPMENT.
(O'Leary) LET'S WALK THROUGH
THE FRANCHISEE MODEL.
I CALL YOU UP
FROM DES MOINES, IOWA.
WHAT DO I PAY YOU?
APPROXIMATELY $150,000.
AND WHAT DO I PAY ONGOING?
6% ROYALTY
WITH A $1,000 MINIMUM.
PER MONTH?
PER MONTH, CORRECT.
HAS ANY FRANCHISEE FAILED?
ABSOLUTELY. WE HAVE
A FEW FAILURES IN THE SYSTEM,
AS ANY FRANCHISE SYSTEM DOES,
BUT OURS ARE MINISCULE.
OKAY, LET'S‐‐LET'S GIVE YOU
THE BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT,
AND LET'S GO BACK TO THE VALUE,
'CAUSE IN THE END,
IT'S JUST ABOUT MONEY. LOVE
KIDS, BUT THIS IS ABOUT MONEY.
WERE YOU MAKING MONEY?
YES, SIR.
WE WERE PROFITABLE
LAST YEAR.
WHAT DID YOU MAKE
AFTER TAXES?
LAST YEAR WE NETTED $125,000
ON JUST OVER $3 MILLION.
AND YOU WANT ME TO PAY YOU
$5 MILLION FOR THAT?
BECAUSE, AGAIN, THIS IS NOT
A SHORT‐TERM PLAY FOR US.
WE HAVE BUILT OUT
AN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT CAN
SUPPORT A SYSTEM FIVE TO TEN
TIMES THE SIZE OF THIS COMPANY.
BUT YOU'RE VALUATING IT
AT $5 MILLION.
CORRECT.
OKAY, BUT WHY WAS THE PROFIT SO
LOW? IT DOESN'T ADD UP FOR ME.
THE INITIAL MILLION DOLLARS THAT
A HANDFUL OF ANGEL INVESTORS
AND US PUT INTO THIS COMPANY
WAS TO GET IT TO THIS POINT.
WE'RE
AT THE TIPPING POINT NOW.
(Robert) SO YOU TOOK
OUTSIDE MONEY IN.
(Stuart) CORRECT.
YOU TOOK A MILLION DOLLARS
IN CASH.
(Stuart and David) CORRECT.
YOU'RE ASKING
FOR A MULTIPLE.
YES, SIR.
A MULTIPLIER OF VALUE,
LET'S CALL IT THAT.
YOU'RE MAKING $125,000
FREE CASH. YOU WANT $5 MILLION.
THAT'S MY PROBLEM.
LOVE THE KIDS, LOVE THE BOOGERS,
LOVE THE BLASTING MASTER,
WHATEVER,
BUT THIS IS ABOUT MONEY.
RIGHT.
I THINK THIS IS
A REAL BUSINESS.
I THINK
THE REAL FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE IS‐‐
IT'S THE NUMBER.
(Stuart) WE WERE THE 21st
FASTEST‐GROWING FRANCHISE
LAST YEAR IN THE COUNTRY.
WE LAUNCHED THIS BUSINESS
IN THE WORST ECONOMY
THE U. S. HAS EVER SEEN.
BUT WHY WOULD YOU COME HERE
WITH A NUMBER LIKE THAT?
YOU‐‐YOU‐‐YOU BASICALLY SAY THAT
YOU NEED STRATEGIC PARTNERS.
MM‐HMM.
WE DO.
BUT YOU WANT TO OVERCHARGE US
AND THEN PUT US TO WORK?
WHAT IS IT YOU THINK IS
REASONABLE?
WELL, MY TIME ALONE TO WORK
ON THIS PROJECT IS WORTH
THE WHOLE COMPANY.
AND YOU'RE TAKING ALL
THE PATENTS INTO CONSIDERATION?
EVERYTHING! EVERYTHING
COMES HOME TO DADDY.
DAVID, THE PROBLEM IS,
THE ECONOMY'S REALLY HARD.
YES, SIR.
I BUY THE DEVELOPMENT COST
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING IN,
BUT $125,000‐‐
REALLY, THE‐‐THE BUSINESS,
ON A PURE MONEY BASIS,
ISN'T WORTH ANYWHERE CLOSE
TO $5 MILLION.
I CAN'T GET OVER THE NUMBER,
AND I CAN'T GET OVER THE FACT
THAT IF I HAVE TO LAY OUT
A HALF A MILLION DOLLARS
OF MY HARD‐EARNED MONEY
AND ONLY GET 10%,
AND THEN I HAVE TO GO
TO WORK,
THE NUMBER JUST DOESN'T
WORK FOR ME. I'M OUT.
MY OWN FEELING ON THIS IS,
IF YOU HAVE TO CONSTANTLY
CREATE NEW PRODUCT,
WHICH IS EXPENSIVE TO DO,
THERE'S NO WAY
YOU'RE GONNA GET AHEAD
OF THE BALL HERE, SO I'M OUT.
HEY, I ADMIRE YOU. YOU'VE MADE
MONEY OFF OF BOOGERS.
I'VE MADE 'EM
OFF OF FART JOKES.
(Barbara laughs)
I'M NOT THROWING
ANY DARTS THERE.
I THINK TO SHELL OUT 400 BUCKS
FOR A KID'S BIRTHDAY PARTY,
IN THIS ECONOMY, I MEAN, IT'S‐‐
IT'S AN EXTRA WHEN PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING TO PAY THE MORTGAGE
OR BUY GROCERIES, AND‐‐
(David) BUT IF YOU THINK
ABOUT IT, IN THIS DAY AND AGE,
SOMEBODY MIGHT NOT GET THAT
NEW CAR, THEY MIGHT NOT GET
THAT NEW HOUSE OR TAKE
THAT VACATION, BUT THEY'RE NOT
GONNA CHEAT THEIR KID
OUT OF A BIRTHDAY PARTY.
SURE THEY ARE, IF THEY CAN'T
AFFORD THEIR MORTGAGE.
NO, NO.
MY DAD USED TO TURN ON
THE SPRINKLER...
(Daymond) YEAH. YEAH.
AND TELL US IT WAS
A WATER PARK. I MEAN...
(sharks laugh)
I THINK IT JUST TAKES TOO LONG
TO EVER GET YOUR MONEY BACK,
SO GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
I HOPE YOU MAKE A BILLION,
BUT I'M OUT.
DAVID, IT'S NOT WORTH
$5 MILLION. YOU KNOW THAT.
I UNDERSTAND,
BUT WE'RE NEGOTIABLE.
BUT TO COME OUT HERE
AND ASK ME TO VALUE THIS
AT $5 MILLION...
YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALMOST AN INSULT.
(Robert) MY ISSUE IS,
YOU CAN'T CONTINUE TO MAKE MONEY
UNLESS YOU DEVELOP NEW PRODUCT,
WHICH IS A SUNK COST FOR YOU
THAT YOU CAN'T GET BACK
FROM THE FRANCHISEES.
I HAVE AN ISSUE
WITH THAT MODEL.
FOR THAT REASON, I'M OUT.
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN IS THE LAST CHANCE
FOR THE PIKOFF BROTHERS
TO SEAL A DEAL.
I'LL MAKE YOU AN OFFER, OKAY?
LET'S START WITH THIS.
I'M GONNA BE REALISTIC
AND DEAL IN THE REAL WORLD.
YOU'RE OFF IN THE FANTASY LAND
WITH THE ROBOT.
I'M BACK HERE ON EARTH.
I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
A FULL PREMIUM ON THIS THING
AND SAY IT'S WORTH
A MILLION BUCKS.
HOWEVER, I NEED CONTROL, SO I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU $500,000 FOR 51%.
WELL, THAT'S NOT SOMETHING
THAT WE COULD JUSTIFY
THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO US.
YOU ONLY MADE $125,000.
TODAY WE HAVE
A MASSIVE CONSUMER DEMAND.
WE HAVE A 99.9%
CUSTOMER SATISFACTION RATING.
WE HAVE SUCCESSFUL FRANCHISEES
THAT ARE EXPANDING.
WE HAVE A BUSINESS MODEL THAT
WORKS ON A CORPORATE LEVEL
THAT'S PROFITABLE.
YOU KNOW, IF YOU BLINDFOLDED ME
RIGHT NOW, THAT'S THE SAME PITCH
I GOT ALL MORNING FROM
TEN GUYS. SAME STORY‐‐
"THE FUTURE'S SO BRIGHT, I GOTTA
WEAR SHADES, AND I GOT A ROBOT."
ALL YOU GOT IS
$125,000 CASH.
THAT'S THE ONLY THING
THAT'S REAL TO ME.
STUART, WHAT'S
YOUR COUNTER TO HIM?
IS THAT THE ONLY OFFER
ON THE TABLE?
(O'Leary) I LOOKED
AT YOUR $125,000 OF CASH
THAT YOU GENERATED,
ALL RIGHT?
I GAVE YOU
A GENEROUS MULTIPLIER ON THAT
THAT TOOK THE VALUE
OF THIS BUSINESS,
NOT TO THE $5 MILLION
THAT YOU WANTED,
BUT TO THE $1 MILLION
THAT IT'S WORTH.
AND SO I'M WILLING TO GIVE
YOU $500,000 FOR 51%,
BECAUSE YOU ACTUALLY NEED ME
TO HELP YOU.
LISTEN, IT'S TIME
TO MAKE A DECISION.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
♪♪♪
FOUR SHARKS ARE OUT.
DAVID AND STUART HAVE ONE OFFER
ON THE TABLE
FROM KEVIN O'LEARY,
WHO IS OFFERING
THE $500,000 THEY'RE SEEKING.
HOWEVER, HE WANTS
A 51% CONTROLLING STAKE
IN THE COMPANY.
LISTEN, IT'S TIME
TO MAKE A DECISION.
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
TELL YOU WHAT.
CAN YOU GIVE US A MINUTE?
ABSOLUTELY.
YES.
(lowered voice) ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE DOWN TO ONE.
(lowered voice)
THERE'S ONE SHARK, BUT 51%?
GIVING HIM
CONTROLLING INTEREST?
THERE'S NO WAY WE CAN GIVE UP
CONTROL OF THE COMPANY.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE
ON ANY LEVEL.
WELL, NOT
AT A MILLION‐DOLLAR VALUATION.
WE HAVE A MILLION DOLLARS
IN IT TO GET TO HERE.
SO WHY DON'T WE GO BACK
WITH $500,000 FOR 25%?
IF WE WANT TO DO A DEAL
WITH HIM,
THAT'S PROBABLY
WHAT IT WOULD TAKE.
I STILL THINK
IT'S A CHEAP DEAL,
BUT IT'S PROBABLY WHAT IT WOULD
TAKE TO CLOSE A DEAL WITH HIM.
$500,000, 25%,
AND THAT'S IT?
THAT'S IT.
THEY DON'T SEE‐‐THEY HAVE
TO SEE THE VISION OF IT.
LET'S GO.
WELL, YOU'RE
A BRILLIANT BUSINESSMAN.
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY
ALSO HUMBLE.
THANK YOU.
(sharks laugh)
WE WOULD... (laughs)
WE WOULD LOVE
TO HAVE YOU ON THE TEAM.
WE THINK YOU COULD BE
VERY STRATEGIC FOR US.
A CONTROLLING POSITION
IN OUR COMPANY
IS NOT SOMETHING WE'RE ABLE
OR WILLING TO DO.
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE TO US
ON ANY LEVEL. HOWEVER‐‐
WHY?
BECAUSE WE HAVE
A PROVEN TRACK RECORD.
WE HAVE
A PROVEN BUSINESS MODEL.
WE HAVE SUCCESSFUL FRANCHISEES,
AND WE HAVE HAPPY CONSUMERS.
LET ME ASK YOU SOMETHING,
MY FRIEND,
IF I GAVE YOU $500,000
OF MY OWN MONEY,
WOULD I BE YOUR SINGLE
LARGEST SHAREHOLDER TODAY?
YES.
WHY SHOULDN'T I HAVE CONTROL?
MONEY ALWAYS CONTROLS
EVERYTHING ALL OF THE TIME.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS.
IF YOU'D BE WILLING
TO BE A PARTNER
WITH A 25% EQUITY STAKE
FOR A $500,000 INVESTMENT,
WE'D LOVE TO HAVE YOU
ON THE TEAM.
I CAN'T GET THERE.
I HAVE TO GO WITH MY GUT
AND WHAT THE VALUE
OF THIS BUSINESS IS,
AND THE ONLY THING THAT SPEAKS
TO ME IS MONEY. THAT'S IT.
I HAVE A SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP
WITH IT.
I'M A GREAT PARTNER
BECAUSE OF THAT.
I HAVE TO HAVE 51%.
YOU GET A CHECK FOR $500,000.
WE MARCH OFF
IN THE FUTURE.
WE BLAST EVERYBODY
WITH NERF BALLS.
(Stuart and David laugh)
COME ON, GUYS.
BE REALISTIC.
YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T GET
ANY MONEY FROM A BANK.
LET'S BE HONEST
WITH EACH OTHER.
OUR DECISION REALLY IS NOT
MONEY FROM A BANK.
IT'S A REASONABLE VALUATION THAT
WE CAN GET COMFORTABLE WITH
VERSUS CONTINUED ORGANIC GROWTH.
I THINK WE'RE DONE.
YOU SAID NO.
YOU LEAVE THE TANK,
WE DON'T MAKE A DEAL‐‐
IT'S LIKE A MEMORY WIPE.
(imitates whoosh)
'CAUSE THERE'S ANOTHER GUY,
ANOTHER ROBOT, ANOTHER STORY,
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY,
AND I WILL GIVE THEM THE MONEY,
AND THEY WILL BECOME RICH.
IT WON'T BE A BRAND
LIKE GAMES2U.
THERE'S A MILLION STORIES
LIKE YOURS, MY FRIENDS.
THAT'S WHY BEING AN ENTREPRENEUR
IS SO WONDERFUL.
EVERY DAY I OPEN THE DOOR,
AND THERE'S A NEW OPPORTUNITY.
TWO GUYS WITH A ROBOT.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
(Robert) THANKS, GUYS.
(Stuart) THERE WAS NO WAY
WE WERE WILLING TO GIVE UP
51% OF OUR COMPANY AND CONTROL
TO SOMEONE LIKE KEVIN O'LEARY.
HE DOESN'T HAVE‐‐
HE DOESN'T SEE OUR VISION.
HE DOESN'T SEE
WHERE THIS COMPANY CAN GO
AND UNDERSTAND
THE POSSIBILITIES.
IT'S JUST NOT POSSIBLE
TO GIVE UP CONTROL
TO SOMEBODY LIKE THAT.
THEY REALLY SHOULD'VE DONE
THE DEAL.
THEY JUST WERE GREEDY.
I SHOULD OWN THIS ROBOT.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
YOU LOOK LIKE THE ROBOT.
(robotic voice)
ROBERT, I'M GOING TO KILL YOU.
(laughs)
(cackles)
GEE, THIS IS FUN.
HOW MUCH IS THIS AGAIN‐‐
A MILLION BUCKS?
YOU KNOW, MAYBE I'LL JUST
BUY ONE OF THESE.
EVERYBODY'S GOING TO DIE.
(sharks laugh)